a very important forecast for the
holiday weekend there's a lot of wind in
it everybody so just count on it being
breezy to windy whatever you have to do
outdoors beautiful sunshine as we look
across the city this morning we have a
lot of 80s around the las vegas valley
now and 78 out at red rock and it's
breezy especially the south end of the
valley and out at red rock and up in the
spring mountains we've had wind gusts
over 30 miles an hour in the mountains
up there at kyle canyon 64 in cali any
70 in indian springs 80 in perum 84 in
boulder city we've got 88 in laughlin 79
in kingman 60's up there in cedar city
you see 64 in cali any 50s in reno and
tonopah and ely this morning just wanted
to give you the very latest the western
drought
actually the whole us
drought monitor released the maps and
the numbers yesterday
but for the west especially the
southwest right here in southern nevada
boy we are looking at exceptional
drought for all of clark county
exceptional drought it's about as bad as
it gets for us so when we say please be
careful with the fireworks this weekend
and the wind and the dry conditions
boy we mean it it is just critical 103
today tomorrow 100 on sunday july 4th 99
degrees that's awesome for us but it
will be
critically dry as the southwest winds
continue to push the monsoon moisture
over the four corners we've got fire
weather warnings that have been issued
for saturday through monday now we're
looking at saturday morning all the way
until monday evening for all of southern
nevada and northwest arizona 78 up on
the mountain those winds 25 30 miles an
hour out at the lake just so important
to wear
life jackets they're searching for a
woman now who fell off a jet ski
yesterday with no life jacket on they
have not found her yet 104 at the lake
and again this 103 today uv index of 11
you've got to have the sunscreen on stay
hydrated get lots of extra water for
your barbecues pool parties whatever
you're doing next week we heat right
back up 105 thursday could even be 110
plus on friday